number 10 have confirmed that Liz truss
is meeting Graham Brady number 10 have
confirmed that this is at Liz truss's
request the meeting is happening inside
Downing Street now often a prime
minister will meet with the chair of the
back bench 1922 commit committee who's
able to tell her whether or not the Tory
MPS in Parliament have confidence in her
those meetings happen quite a lot but
rarely are they confirmed like this
rarely can they be are they done inside
Downing Street where we're able to see
Graham Brady going in and out we also
know that important government business
has been delayed in order to deal with
what is quite clearly continuing
political crisis at the heart of power
it goes without saying that this does
not look like a particularly good sign
for Liz trust the last 24 hours have
been chaotic on a scale that few round
here can remember with votes and
sackings and cabinet minister is off and
trenchant letters and cabinet minus ex
cabinet ministers putting in their
letters to Graham Brady all in the last
few hours calling for Liz truss to stand
down the question now really is what is
going on in Liz truss's head
what are the people immediately around
her saying source is telling me that
even Therese coffee thinks that them
that that she recognizes the scale of
the challenge that Liz truss's
government have Therese coffee of course
the Deputy Prime Minister and a key Ally
and friend of Liz truss so if there were
difficult conversations to be had
Therese coffee would be one of the
people that was having it but I think
that the fact that Graham Brady has gone
in uh in a way that we can see into
Danning Street for a meeting this
morning that wasn't planned but is now
confirmed it is a sign that we could be
reaching a new stage of this crisis for
Liz trust because Graham Brady will know
what every Tory MP that you talk to
around here in private is telling you
that on top of the 14 publicly declared
MPS who think that Liz truss should go
there are dozens and dozens quite
possibly in three figures conservative
MPS who privately think that she should
go think that after the u-turns that
she's performed in the last few weeks
after the chaos the political chaos that
we've seen of the last 24 hours after
the fact that she stood on a ticket of
pure ideological drive and has had to
junk that entirely appointing people
with pretty different economic views
political views to her key uh great jobs
of State all of those things suggest to
MPS that the time is up remember Anna in
the next 11 days this country has got to
make deeply painful decisions about
where we cut where we trim some of the
essential services that people rely on
Liz trust must arbitrate those arguments
as he stands MPS asking whether that can
be allowed to stand or whether or not
actually it's time in fact for her to
leave sooner rather than later because
her Authority after that chaos in the
Commons last night the sacking and the
unsacking resignation and the
unresignation of her Chief Whip and the
uncertainty about what happens next all
of that means her Authority is under
huge question